♪
>> Tucker: UNIVERSITIES ARE
OBSESSED, THEY SAY WITH
STAMPING OUT HARASSMENT.
THEY HAVE WHOLE PROGRAMS
DEDICATED TO THAT.
NOT ALL HARASSMENT.
SOME IS FINE IT TURNS OUT.
WOLF A STUDENT WAKE FORREST
IN NORTH CAROLINA.
HE FACED REPEATED HARASSMENT
FOR HIS VIEWS.
SCHOOL OFFICIALS THOUGH SAY
THEY ARE NOT GOING TO DO
ANYTHING ABOUT IT PROBABLY
BECAUSE THEY DON'T LIKE HIS
VIEWS.
RYAN WOLF JOINS US TONIGHT.
RYAN, WHAT HAPPENED?
>> THANKS FOR HAVING ME ON,
TUCKER.
>> Tucker: THANKS.
>> BACK BEFORE THE 2016
ELECTION WE HAD A PANEL TALK
THAT WAS HOSTED BY THE
COLLEGE REPUBLICAN VOTE AND
PUBLICATION ON OUR CAMPUS
BEFORE DURING AND AFTER THIS
EVENT THERE WERE MESSAGES
ABOUT ME ON SOCIAL MEDIA AND
IN GROUP CHATS AND THAT WERE
KIND OF TRYING TO INTIMIDATE
ME AND THEN AFTER THE EVENT
I WAS HANDED A BOX OF
SALTINE CRACKERS AND IN A
GROUP CHAT DURING THE EVENT
A STUDENT PHOTO SHOPPED MY
FACE ONTO THE CRACKER.
OUR SCHOOL HAS FAIRLY STRICT
VERBAL ABUSE, HARASSMENT.
>> Tucker: BY THE WAY, JUST
TO CLARIFY I ASSUME THAT'S A
SLUR AGAINST YOUR ETHNICITY,
CORRECT.
>> YES.
THAT'S HOW IT WAS INTENDED.
ABSOLUTELY.
WE HAVE PRETTY STRICT RULES
ABOUT HARASSMENT AT OUR
SCHOOL WHICH, YOU KNOW,
CLEARLY DON'T ABIDE BY THE
FIRST AMENDMENT.
BUT, WE ARE TRYING TO HOLD
ALL STUDENTS TO THE SAME
STANDARD.
I REPORTED THE CONDUCT.
ACTUALLY AT THE BEHEST OF
ONE OF MY PROFESSORS WHO
USED TO BE AN MSNBC HOST.
MELISSA HARRIS PERRY.
AND SO I SENT IN THESE
REPORTS.
AND THE UNIVERSITY BASICALLY
AFTER SEVERAL LEAKS GAVE ME
THESE OPTIONS I ASKED DO
PRESS CHARGES.
OPEN A SCHOOL JUDICIAL CASE
AGAINST THE STUDENTS WHO
HANDED ME A BOX OF CRACKERS
AND PHOTO SHOPPED MY FACE
ONTO THE BOX OF CRACKERS.
-- FRANK PERSON THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S ELECTION
SOMEHOW JUSTIFIED THEIR
BEHAVIOR EVEN THOUGH THE
INCIDENT HAPPENED BEFORE
ELECTION DAY.
AND THAT IF I BROUGHT A
JUDICIAL CASE IT WOULD MAKE
THINGS WORSE FOR ME.
WE WERE HEADING INTO FINALS
WEEK AND AT THE END OF THE
SEMESTER I WANTED THIS TO BE
OVER SO HE WOULD SAY --
>> Tucker: DEAN GOLDSTEIN
SAID, I WANT TO MAKE SURE
I'M NOT MISCHARACTERIZING
THIS THE PRESIDENT'S
ELECTION SOMEHOW JUSTIFIED
THIS ATTACK ON YOU?
>> YEAH, HE DOESN'T SAY
THINGS IN SHORT SENTENCES
LIKE THAT.
WHAT I TOOK AWAY FROM THAT
PART OF THE CONVERSATION WAS
THAT HE WAS TRYING TO
JUSTIFY THEIR BEHAVIOR
BECAUSE IT WAS A RESPONSE TO
THE ELECTION OF PRESIDENT
TRUMP.
>> Tucker: I MEAN, THAT'S --
I DON'T EVEN KNOW WHAT TO
SAY.
>> IT DOESN'T MAKE ANY
SENSE.
>> Tucker: NO, IT DOESN'T.
AND I ASSUME THAT -- IF YOU
HAD BEEN A DIFFERENT KIND OF
PERSON, THIS WOULD HAVE BEEN
SWIFTLY PUNISHED, I ASSUME,
RIGHT?
>> RIGHT, EXACTLY.
WE HAD A RACIAL SLUR
INCIDENT JUST A FEW WEEKS
AGO AND LET ME BE CLEAR.
I'M NOT EQUATING WHAT WAS
SAID BY THIS GIRL SAID ABOUT
ME.
BUT THAT STUDENT WAS ASKED
TO LEAVE OUR SCHOOL ABOUT
TWO DAYS LATER.
THIS TOOK SEVERAL WEEKS AND
THEY WOULDN'T IVAN OPEN A
JUDICIAL CASE ABOUT
HARASSMENT.
EVEN JUST KIND OF LEAVING
THE RACE PART OUT OF IT.
>> Tucker: DEAN GOLDSTEIN
DIDN'T SAY IN THAT CASE
BARACK OBAMA WAS ELECTED
PRESIDENT NINE YEARS AGO.
UNDERSTANDABLE THAT PEOPLE
MIGHT DO THAT.
THAT WASN'T THE EXCUSE HE
GAVE IN THAT CASE I ASSUME,
RIGHT?
>> OH, NO.
YEAH.
THIS INCIDENT JUST HAPPENED
A FEW WEEKS AGO HERE.
BUT, YEAH, NO.
IT MAKES NO SENSE.
I TOLD HIM IN THAT MEETING
THAT, YOU KNOW, INDIVIDUALS
HAVE TO BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE
FOR THEIR INDIVIDUAL ACTIONS
UNDER THE RULES WE HAVE AT
THE SCHOOL.
AND YOU KNOW, IF I HAD IT MY
WAY, WE WOULD JUST ABIDE BY
THE FIRST AMENDMENT AND WE
WOULDN'T HAVE ALL THESE
RULES.
>> Tucker: I GET IT.
>> IF WE ARE GOING TO HAVE
THESE STRICT RULES AND
BIASED REPORTING SYSTEM,
THEN EVERYBODY NEEDS TO BE
HELD ACCOUNT BEING THE EXACT
SAME WAY.
>> Tucker: RYAN, I REALLY
APPRECIATE HOW BRAVE YOU ARE
TO COME ON AND HOW CLEARLY
YOU EXPRESSED THAT AND IN A
WAY YOU ARE A CREDIT TO WAKE
FORREST BECAUSE YOU ARE
IMPRESSIVE THE SCHOOL IS
OBVIOUSLY NOT LIVING UP TO
ITS OWN STANDARDS.